when we think of racial injustice we
think police brutality or the criminal
justice system but what about our air
and water environmental racism it's
about policies and practices that
discriminate against communities of
color by making them live near landfills
sewage plants and other polluting
facilities and while poverty has a lot
to do with it the leading environmental
justice expert told me this racism
Trump's class even middle-income African
Americans are more likely to live in
mortal ooze neighborhood in fact one
study found that black Americans making
fifty to sixty thousand dollars a year
are more likely to live in polluted
neighborhoods than white Americans who
make just ten thousand dollars a year
Flint Michigan is a textbook case of
environmental racism
it's where 100,000 residents have been
poisoned with toxic water contaminated
by high levels of lead why because the
state was trying to save a buck
Flint is around fifty seven percent
black with 40% of its population living
in poverty residents protested the dirty
water for over a year but were ignored
and that's how environmental racism
plays out minority communities have much
less political clout so regulators can
and often do ignore them and not far
from Flint is Detroit where 83% of the
population is black it's home to the
most polluted ZIP code in Michigan zip
code is the most powerful predictor of
health and all communities at all zip
codes are not created equal
Southwest Detroit is surrounded by a lot
of industry like salt mining steel
production tar sands oil refining and
coal burning and that's meant that 1.6
million pounds of chemicals enter that
community yearly
not coincidentally Wayne County where
Detroit is has the highest number of
children's asthma cases in the state but
look environmental racism isn't just a
Michigan story it's an American story
take for example Louisiana's cancer
alley an 85 mile stretch along the
Mississippi River it's known for its
over 200 petrochemical plants
a high rate of cancer mainly among black
residents so is there anyone protecting
folks from environmental racism
well there's supposed to be the
Environmental Protection Agency has a
special department called the Office of
Civil Rights but in its 22 year history
the office has never formally found a
single case of discrimination in fact
more than 90% of communities that make
complaints find them rejected or
dismissed on top of that The Guardian
newspaper recently revealed that US
authorities across the country are
deliberately distorting water tests in
cities like Detroit and Philadelphia to
minimize a reported amount of lead in
the water environmental racism while not
always the most visible form is also
widespread so when is enough enough
[Music]